l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement la parole est à Monsieur
Jocelin des pour le groupe rassemblement
national merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique monsieur le ministre quand le
groupe américain mondelaise
international annonce la fermeture de
l'usine Belin à châteautiierry c'est
tout le département deine qui souffre
depuis 1931 les Castels théodoriciens
sont fiers de préparer chaque jour les
biscuits que l'on retrouve dans les
poches des écoliers français à l'heure
du goûter tout comme nos agriculteurs
ils travaillent pour nous nourrir et ne
demandent qu'à vivre de leur travail
alors que de l'Assemblée nationale au
Sénat sur les plateaux télé dans les
journaux vous avancez fi né au vent pour
vanter vos mérites et annoncer vos
chiffres de soi-disant
réindustrialisation de la France en
province c'est la réalité qui nous
éclate sous nos yeux bien que créé à
châteautiierri les pépitos sous leur
forme poquitos seront désormais
fabriqués en république tque de l'an à
châteautiierry en passant par
saintgobin les sites industriels axonnis
ferment les uns après les autres sans
que vous ne bougiez le petit doigt
depuis une semaine ce sont 81 familles
qui ne dorment plus car ils se demandent
comment ils vont payer leur loyer leur
cadit leur facture électricité qui
explose malgré vos belles paroles et vos
promesses non tenues de non augmentation
des tarifs depuis 10 ans les ouvriers
belins se sont adapté ont augmenté leur
productivité ils ont fait preuve
d'humilité et de dignité ces qualités
aujourd'hui qui vous manqu pour sauver
notre patrimoine industriel ma question
est donc la suivante comment
comptez-vous concrètement œuvrer pour
sauver ces
emplois je vous remercie monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le
Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député de C je
partage votre inquiétude et je partage
la douleur de tous les salariés qui ont
appris à quelques jours que l'usine
allait fermer cette usine qui comportait
1200 salariés il y a encore quelques
années 60 aujourd'hui nous veillerons au
reclassement de chacun des salariés nous
demandons au groupe mondelaise de faire
le néaire pour reclasser chaque salarié
et je vous propose de vous associer au
travail que nous allons engager avec
l'entreprise avec le maire de
château-tiri pour trouver un repreneur
car pour moi l'essentiel aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y ait une reprise
industrielle sur ce site industriel et
que le site industriel ne ferme pas
ensuite pour le reste et pour la
politique industrielle que nous menons
je regarde juste les chiffres même si je
le redis je vais me battre pour le site
industriel de châau satiri il n'empêche
que dans un pays qui depuis 40 ans a
détruit 2 millions d'emplois industriels
a fermé des milliers de sites
industriels nous avons recréé des
centaines de sites industriels sur notre
pays et nous avons recréé 100000 emplois
industriels pour la première fois depuis
une trentaine d'années et d'ailleurs le
département de l'INE au-delà de
châteautiierry a pu en bénéficier
département qui est dynamique
département qui beaucoup de créations
d'entreprise donc je vous propose de
nous mobiliser tous ensemble pour avoir
une réindustrialisation en bon ordre du
site mondelaise à châteautiry je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre monsieur
le député
allez-y monsieur le ministre vos belles
promesses on sait où elles finissent
aujourd'hui ce sont des actes que nous
voulons je vous invite donc dès demain
vous joindre à moi pour nous rendre
ensemble sur le site historique de Belin
afin de rencontrer les responsables du
personnel et la
direction je vous
[Musique]
remercie la parole pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et républicaine est à Madame
Soumia
BR merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues je souhaite tout d'abord
associer mon groupe à l'hommage rendu
aux Invalides aux victimes du 7 octobre
2023 en Israël il n'y a pas de mots
assez fort pour qualifier les crimes
commis par le Hamas nous adressons nos
pensées aux victimes aux familles et aux
otage dont nous espérons la libération
rapide l'horreur de ces vies briser
ne peut justifier ce qui se passe
actuellement à Gaza avec une délégation
de parlementaires et d'élus locaux nous
nous sommes rendu à Rafa à la frontière
de Gaza en Égypte les témoignages que
nous avons entendu sont bouleversants et
je voudrais témoigner de ce que vit la
population Gazaoui à l'hôpital d'Al
rasherf j'ai échangé avec des mères et
des enfants qui m'ont raconté comment
blessés ils ont marché pendant des jours
pour se rendre à la frontière égyptienne
pour y être soigné nous avons entendu
les témoignages d'humanitaire dont
Raphaël piti qui raconte le sort de ces
civils qui n'ont plus de quoi se nourrir
plus d'endroit où se réfugier ni
d'hôpitaux pour se faire soigner la
bande de Gaza est un champ de ruine où
la population vit recluse sur 34 km² il
n'y a pas que les bombes qui tuent il y
a aussi la pénurie désespérée de
médicaments de nourriture d'eau les
Gazaoui sont entassé dans le seul
hôpital en service et qui est au bord de
l'effondrement la France doit maintenir
et amplifier les aides accordées à
l'unra seule organisation présente pour
venir en aide au civils la diplomatie
française envoie des médicaments et du
matériel sur place certes mais comment
s'en satisfaire lorsque les autorités
israéliennes rejettent ce matériel sans
raison valable ce qui se passe est
inhumain monsieur le ministre la voix de
la France est importante quelles sont
les actions que notre diplomatie met en
œuvre pour obtenir un cesser le feu
immédiat est
permanent je vous remercie ma chè
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane sjouré ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères merci madame la
présidente madame la députée merci pour
votre question et au vu des tensions de
la situation humanitaire que que vous
évoquez et du risque pour la sécurité au
Proche Orient je me suis rendu ces
derniers jours en Égypte en Jordanie en
Israël en Palestine et et également au
Liban la France peut être fière d'être
le pays européen le plus actif sur le
terrain en partenaire d'ailleurs
partenariat avec les pays arabes de la
région je pense notamment à l'Égypte et
la Jordanie la position de la France
vous la connaissez madame la députés
nous l'exposons ici depuis le début de
ce conflit condamnation des actes du
terrorisme du Hamas et demande de
libération immédiate des otages soutien
humanitaire et et appel à un arrêt des
combat pour mettre fin aux souffrances
des civils à Gaza nécessité d'une
solution politique pour sortir de la
crise seule viable étant celle des deux
états cette solution politique que nous
partageons ici de manière majoritaire
dans cet hémicycle j'ai porté ces
messages et cette exigence auprès de
l'ensemble de mes interlocuteurs pour ce
qui est de l'unra madame la députée vous
le savez la France n'avait pas prévu de
versement avant le 2e trimestre nous
avons pas suspendu nos versements
contrairement d'ailleurs à un certain
nombre d'autres pays occidentaux mais
nous nous appuierons sur l'audit
indépendante des Nations Unies qui nous
devra nous garantir ce qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs par le passé puisque les
accusations sont graves mais en même
temps nous donner des garanties pour
l'avenir pour que ces financements
puisse être encore donné par la France
merci madame la députée je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre minist la parole
est à Monsieur Bertrand petit pour le
groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre remonter
est très en colère c'est l'état d'esprit
des milliers de sinistrés du pays de
saint-homer victimes des inondations
malgré les visites ministérielles et les
promesses ils ont le sentiment que rien
n'avance pourtant il y a urgence urgence
tout d'abord à les indemniser ils sont
encore très nombreux à attendre le
passage de l'expert ou son rapport trop
d'incer entour aussi la mise en œuvre du
fond Barnier et les conditions de rachat
et d'indemnisation pour ceux qui savent
qu'ils ne regagneront jamais leur maison
pour eux le temps presse urgence
également à mobiliser des aides
immédiates pour permettre aux sinistrés
de supporter les coups de vétusté alors
que les assurances traînent les pieds à
indemniser pour l'achat de matériaux de
reconstruction ou encore pour le
paiement de la taxe foncière pour ceux
qui ne retourneront pas dans leur
domicile avant de très longs mois dans
toute la vallée industrielle ouvrière de
huiserern blandec et Arc des familles
modestes ont tout perdu face à leur
détresse la réponse de l'État doit être
forte et rapide or dans ces communes les
sinistrés déplurent l'absence
significative de travaux de curage de
nettoyage et d'enlèvement des embacles
des cours d'eau les collectivités sont
au rendez-vous mais font avec leurs
moyens comme vous l'avez dit Monsieur le
Premier Ministre à situation
exceptionnelle mesures exceptionnelles
quelles sont-elles urgence encore à
renfor for a moderniser le parc des
pompes vieillissantes de l'institution
des watering pour l'évacuation à la mer
et le cuirage des canaux de VNF comme le
bief du haupont à saintomè envasé depuis
des années je le réclame depuis des mois
par des courriers restés sans réponse à
votre Ministre Christophe Béchu urgence
enfin à prendre en charge les franchises
les franchises des artisans et des
commerçants sinistrés vous en avez acté
le principe lors de votre déplacement à
clermaray j'ai cru comprendre que cela
n'était plus d'actualité qu'en est-il
Monsieur le Premier Ministre au moment
où vous vous apprêtez à revenir dans
l'odarois je peux vous assurer que la
colère est particulièrement palpable en
dépit de certaines déclarations rien
n'est réglé le temps de la compassion et
des promesses irrévolu nos habitants à
bout attendent des actes du concret
merci beaucoup merci la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires monsieur le député
Bertrand
petit
nous avons installé il y a 15 jours un
comité ministériel de suivi qui se
réunit tous les 15 jours le 1er février
le décret curage a été publié au Journal
officiel conformément aux engagements le
2 février le décret sur la prise en
charge par le fond Barnier à hauteur de
100 % des batardau a été pris en charge
le jour de sa nomination le Premier
ministre s'est rendu sur place il a
annoncé des aides pour les très petites
entreprises les modalités ont été
précisées à l'ensemble des élus de la
semaine dernière et correspondent aux
engagements pris à clermis à hauteur de
5000 € pour ces société le fond des 50
millions d'euros premis par le Président
de la République a déjà débouché sur les
15 premiers millions versés au sein de
la préfecture du pastecalais et ont
permis de donner la gage aux élus du
financement du fonctionnement des pompes
sur la période les travaux d'urgence ont
commencés que ce soit par VNF sur
l'udruck sur l'enlèvement des embacles
sur laa et je comprends évidemment la
colère mais je n'accepte pas que vous
puissiez dire que rien n'a été fait
parce que prment les collectivités
locales les élus se mobilisent en
parallèle si les solutions miracles
existaient nous le saurions trois
missions on été conduite une pour
regarder précisément ce que les
Hollandais et les Belges ont fait pensez
que pour lutter face à ce type de
phénomène il faut monter des digues ou
uniquement installer des pompes c'est ne
pas mesurer les nécessités d'un plan de
résilience qui tienne compte de ce que
le dérèglement climatique entraîent en
terme de conséquences gérer un plan qui
nous permette sur la durée sur le modèle
du plan Delta de savoir ce que nous
devons faire ce sont les conclusions que
nous aurons à la fin du mois de mars les
modalités pour le rachat des maisons
dans le cadre du fond Barnier là où la
valeur des maisons a été divisée par
deux dans le cadre des dégâts ont été
précisés des éléments le seront à
nouveau par la Préfecture du ménéloire
par la préfecture pardon du pas decalais
dans dans les jours qui viennent et le
Premier ministre aura l'occasion demain
à l'occasion de sa deuxème visite sur
place en moins d'un mois de venir à
nouveau préciser et rappeler la
détermination et la mobilisation de
l'État mettez-vous dans le camp de ceux
qui proposent des solution de ceux qui
font en sorte d'être au côté de ceux qui
sont
sinistr merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
ministre alors monsieur le ministre vous
êtes à 2 minutes 20 donc je pense que je
vous invite à respecter et vous n'avez
plus de temps du tout vous aviez aussi
débordé de 10 secondes donc revenons sur
nos 2 minutes s'il vous plî PL la parole
est à Madame Caroline yadan pour le
groupe
Renaissance madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Stéphane
séjourné ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires
étrangères ramenez-les à la maison
maintenant depuis le 7 octobre 2023 nous
l'avons entendu ce cri de douleur des
familles déchirées mais si dignes qui
n'ont plus de larmes dont les proches
ont été guidnappés et qui sont parfois
confrontés au mensonges que des porteurs
de haine ont
édifiés depuis le 7 octobre 2023 nous
les avons observé les visages de ceux
qui ont été arrachés à leur famille à
l'aube d'une matinée sanglante au cours
de laquelle Allah a été convoquée par
des barbares génocidaires hystérisés
être au tajagaza c'est être privé chaque
jour de la lumière du soleil c'est être
prisonnier dans 700 km de tunnel
construit par le Hamas grâce à la
générosité des nations non pour protéger
la population civil mais pour entreposer
des armes de guerre destinées à tuer
femmes et enfants en Israël être h Tage
à Gaza c'est être privé de médicaments
dont on a besoin et attendre
l'intervention de la Croix-Rouge en
20ain être a Tage à Gaza c'est devenir à
19 ans une esclave sexuelle être otage à
Gaza c'est se dire chaque jour que c'est
peut-être le dernier c'est être privé de
nourriture de parole de sommeil c'est
être insulté humilié et torturé par des
terroristes islamistes endoctrinés à la
haine des Juifs dès le berceau être a
Tage à Gaza c'est avoir 1 an et
s'appelait F Bibas avoir passé le quart
de sa vie privé de liberté être auage à
Gaza c'est aussi dans l'obscurité de
l'incertitude monsieur le ministre
gardez la foi et l'espoir d' être libéré
monsieur le ministre en ce jour où un
hommage national a été rendu aux
victimes du pogrom du 7 octobre quel
moyen la France déploitelle pour venir
en aide aux 136 otages dont trois
français encore aux mains du Hamas je
vous remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane séjourné ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires
étrangères
merci madame la députée Caroline Adam
comme je le disais une de vos collègues
je rentre d'Israël où j'étais lundi à
l'occasion d'une tournée dans la région
et j'ai rencontré les familles de nos
compatriotes encore au tâ des
terroristes du Hamas et j'ai vu leur
douleur vos mots sont touchants et je
pense que nous partageons leur
peine de nouveau ce matin après
l'hommage rendu par la France à ces 42
enfants morts en Israël dans les
attaques barbares du 7 octobre le
président de la République et moi-même
avons de nouveau vu les familles des
otages comme le président de la
République l'a dit ce matin une nouvelle
fois comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
directement comme je le réaff également
à mes
interlocuteurs la libération des otages
tous les otages sans conditions sans
aucune condition madame la députée
demeure la priorité de la France je veux
aussi dire que nous agissons nous
agissons sur le terrain diplomatique
avec nos partenaires les plus engagés
dans cet effort évidemment Israël mais
également le Qatar la Jordanie et
l'Égypte nous agissons également sur le
terrain opérationnel où nous avons mené
d'ailleurs une opération extrêmement
complexe pour fournir des médicaments
aux otages retenu dans la bande de
Gazara alors madame la députée en cette
journée dommage je tiens à réaffirmer
solennellement devant la représentation
nationale que la libération des otages
français à Gaza fait aujourd'hui l'objet
d'une mobilisation entière et totale des
services de l'État merci je remercie je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Damien Maudet
pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la santé quand il
y a des morts on ne fait pas remonter
l'info aux autorités si ça ne fait pas
trop de bruit on met l'incident sous le
tapis voilà ce que nous dit désabusé
dégoûté un chef de service des urgences
et on m'écrit à liimoge ce weekend on a
eu 90 personnes aux urgences ça veut
donc dire qu'il y en avait 70 qui
attendaient dans les couloirs à
Strasbourg le taux d'occupation des lits
de 190 % ils ont même installé une unité
d'urgence sur le parking à carré en
Mayenne à pertui partout en France les
soignants sont dans la survie des
patients sont à l'agonie à ncker les
médecins alertent un enfant meurt tous
les mois faute de pouvoir être opéré sur
le seul mois de décembre 2022 150
personnes seraient décédées aux urgences
faute de prise en charge et alors qu'un
médecin déplorer un manque de moyens ce
soir-là à hier le jeune Lucas 25 ans est
décédé d'une SPTI s'est mis après une
nuit dans un couloir soignant en survie
patient à l'agonie et les drames se
multiplient tu casses tu répares tu ses
tu nettoies à scène le Premier ministre
mais vous quand est-ce que ça s'applique
pour vous quand est-ce que vous allez
réparer tout ce que vous avez détruit
parce que si nous en sommes là c'est de
votre faute depuis 2017 vous avez
supprimé 3000 lit d'hospitalisation
entre 2020 et 2022 le nombre
d'infirmiers manquant est passé de 60000
est passé à 60000 une multiplication par
8 vous les dégoûter ils partent pour les
Français c'est tu casass surépart mais
pour le gouvernement c'est tu casses et
tu continues de casser alors que les
soignants étouffent en octobre vous avez
passé par 493 4 milliards d'euros
d'économie sur leur dos les patients
s'entassent dans les couloirs parfois
meurent dans ces couloirs et vous
proposez de faire payer encore plus cher
l'accès à la santé madame la ministre
des gens peuvent décéder seuls sur des
brancards faute de prise en charge faute
de personne alors combien de Burnout
combien de services fermés et combien de
DRAM avant que vous ne
réagissiez je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine Vautrin ministre du Travail de
la santé et des
solidarités merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Damien modé monsieur
le député chacun le sait dans notre pays
52000 personnes passent chaque jour dans
les services des urgences dont 1000
enfants ça c'est la réalité de ce que
nous vivons au quotidien avec des femmes
et des hommes qui sont particulièrement
mobilisés je veux parler des équipes
soignantes pour autant vous l'avez dit
et je pense que chacun peut le dire ici
chaque mort est évidemment un drame
alors l'engagement du gouvernement est
extrêmement concret et je voudrais le
remettre en avant pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière dans cet hémicycle le
Premier ministre est revenu sur le
service d'accès aux soins nous avons
actuellement une soixantaine de service
d'accès aux soins dans notre pays qui
réunissent précisément les libéraux et
les professionnels hospitaliers
l'objectif c'est que d'ici l'été c'est
pas long d'ici l'été nous ayons des
services d'accès aux soins dans chacun
des départements parce qu'un service
d'accès aux soins dans chaque
département mesdames et messieurs les
députés c'est la certitude d'avoir une
réponse médicalisé en fonction des
besoins de chacun de ces patients
parallèlement à cela dès le mois de
janvier 24 le gouvernement a mis en
place une augmentation des rémunérations
pour les gardes et pour les travaux des
weekend ça aussi c'était attendu c'est
aujourd'hui fait alors maintenant ce que
nous avons également fait que je
voudrais rappeler ici c'est le séure
fonctionnement qui a permis
l'accompagnement financier des
personnels il reste à mettre en place et
je me'y suis engagé dès maintenant le
segéure investissement 19 milliards qui
répondront aux besoins de soins de suite
aux besoins de lit parce que c'est ça la
mobilisation du gouvernement pour
l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens je vous remercie madame la
ministre une
seconde je pense qu'aujourd'hui vous
n'aurez convaincu personne et j'espère
que vous irez dire au soignants une
seconde la parole est à Monsieur
Aurélien tacher pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre des Affaires
étrangères depuis l'annonce dimanche par
le président mackyall du report de
l'élection président le Sénégal est au
bord du chaos alors que depuis plus d'un
an il a multiplié les manipulations pour
influer sur sa succession c'est le
principe même de celle-ci qui n'est
maintenant plus garantie il a d'abord
laissé planer le doute sur sa volonté de
briguer un troisème mandat quand la
Constitution lui en autorise deux puis a
renoncé face à la colère populaire le
pouvoir sénégalais a alors multiplié
dans une pure logique de l'au faer les
procès contre son principal opposant
Ousman Sonko qui a finalement été
déclaré inéligible pour avoir diffamé
l'un de ses ministres mais les
différents partis d'opposition n'ont pas
renoncé sentant l'élection à haut risque
pour son dauphin mackyall est alors
passé en force et a fait adopter une loi
qui reporte les élections de la fin du
mois à la fin de l'année cette loi
proscrit aussi désormais la procédure
des parrainages citoyens éliminant ainsi
tous les candidats légalement désignés
par le peuple monsieur le ministre
au-delà de son contenu antidémocratique
vous avez vu comme moi les conditions
dans lesquelles cette loi a été adoptée
en l'absence des députés d'opposition
que la police a fait évacuer de force de
l'Assemblée le 23 juin 1789 au nom de
ses collègues refusant d'obéir au roi
mIRABO a prononcé ses fameux mots allez
dire au roi que nous sommes ici par la
volonté du peuple et que nous n'en
sortirons que par la force des
bayonnettes et bien monsieur le ministre
c'est exactement ce qui est arrivé au
député sénégalais certains ont
d'ailleurs été encore arrêtés hier et
face à cela la France patrie de la
démocratie et malgré un douloureux passé
colonial grand ami du Sénégal ne peut
rester silencieuse alors que nos échecs
sur lesquels ont prospéré nos ennemis
nous ont totalement marginalisé au Sahel
notre voix la vôre est plus que jamais
attendu à Dakar en recevant Macky Sall à
l'Élysée en novembre dernier le
président Macron avait SEM le trouble
mais peut-être avait-il encore le
bénéfice du doute celui-ci n'est
désormais plus permis alors comme
démocrate et internationaliste convaincu
je crois connaître votre engagement
monsieur le ministre et surtout comme
ministre de la France condamnez-vous
clairement le coup d'État institutionnel
en cours au Sénégal et appelez-vous
comme l'Union africaine et la CDAO au
maintien des élections le 25 février
prochain je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane séjournée ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères merci Madame
la la présidente monsieur député
Aurélien
taché nous suivons la situation au
Sénégal avec une très grande attention
la décision de reporter de près de 10
mois l'élection présidentielle et
d'allonger d'autant le mandat du
président plonge le Sénégal dans une
période d'incertitude politique majeure
c'est une situation très préoccupante
nous appelons les autorités à préserver
la longue et solide tradition
démocratique et à garantir l'ensemble
des libertés publiques vous le savez le
gouvernement doit répondre aux
aspirations légitimes de sa population
et notamment de sa jeunesse et je sais
que nous partageons également ce point
de vue le peuple sénégalais doit pouvoir
choisir librement ses dirigeants
conformément aux règles de l'État de
droit de la démocratie sénégalaise et
nous appelons les autorités à organiser
l'élection présidentielle le plus
rapidement possible conformément à la
constitution du Sénégal
c'est ce que les pays et vous l'avez
mentionné d'Afrique de l'Ouest on ont
rappelé hier c'est ce que je veux dire
également ici nous nous engagerons avec
tous les acteurs les responsables de la
société civile les oppositions le parti
également présidentiel dans cette voie
et dans cet engagement au dialogue en
tout cas avec force et fierté le Sénégal
doit rester
démocratique je vous remercie monsieur
le
ministre
allez-y vous monsieur le ministre et
n'envoyez pas monsieur
bookel je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur cyil Isaac cbil pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et la cohésion des
territoires en juillet derniier
ellisabeth borne première ministre m'a
confié une mission sur les pfaces les P
fluoré ces substances chimique créé par
l'homme est connu sous l'appellation de
polyon éternel ces pfases sont utilisés
depuis plus de 70 ans par les
industriels en raison de leur propriété
exceptionnelle elles résistent à l'eau
au cœur gras au hautes température et
sont faiblement dégradables mais revers
de la médaille ils sont à l'origine
d'une pollution historique qui pose un
véritable problème de santé publique car
ils sont toxiques entraînent les
troubles immunitaires des infertilités
des cancers cette polluation cette
pollution nous la voyons surgir
régulièrement dans tous les territoires
encore récemment à Saint-Lin dans le
gare par rapport à ça nous avons faire à
deux problèmes réagir face à ses
pollutions historiques en faisant cesser
rapidement les rejets de Pias comme
Arkema a su le faire à pierbénite dans
ma circonscription en dépolluant
notamment les eaux destinées à la
consommation humaine enfin restreint
l'utilisation despéface en fonction de
leur usage nous savons que certains
péfaces sont essentiels comme par
exemple dans le secteur de la santé je
rappelle que beaucoup de dispositifs
médicaux en ont besoin et même le
certains médicaments comme le prosac en
sont et ici aussi pour la transition
écologique pour les batteries et les
éoliennes d'autres sont superflus même
futiles comme le fart par exemple pour
le s ils peuvent être interdits monsieur
le ministre mes questions sont les
suivantes dans quelle mesure la France
soutient-elle l'initiative de 5 pays
européens de restriction de l'ensemble
de la famille d'pface et ceci en
fonction des usages deuxème question
quelle est ou quelle sera la position de
la France vis-à-vis de la révision du
règlement européen sur les emballages
alimentaires règlement actuellement
discutés dans le cadre du trilogue
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires pour une
durée de 2 minutes merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Député Isaac Sib
vous nous avez remis il y a quelques
jours ce rapport avec 18 recommandations
qui s'articulent finalement autour de
deux grands axes mieux connaître pour
mieux lutter et vous pointez le fait que
derrière cette appellation de pifas il y
a quelques molécules dont on connaît les
propriétés mais il y a une immense
majorité pour lesqueles nous avons des
données qui sont parcellaires ou
absentes et qui nécessitent en matière
de métrologie en matière d'établissement
de normes de rejet en matière de travaux
sur les interactions d'un certain nombre
de monomères mais aussi de polymères
pouvoir faire progresser la recherche et
la science ça rejoint la philosophie
globale du plan ministériel le premier
dont notre pays s'est doté il y a un peu
plus d'un an en six axes qui
comportaient une part européenne sur
laquelle vous m'interpellez de manière
plus
spécifique dans le courant de l'année
2023 6 pays le Danemark la Norvège
l'Allemagne les Pays-Bas et la France ça
fait 5 mais j'ai oublié le 6e se sont
mobilisés pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions nous doter d'une
réglementation dans le cadre des
emballages qui soient extrêmement
ambitieus et qui pose des principes
d'interdiction nous faisons partie de
cette coalition nous la soutenons et
nous souhaitons que nous puissions agir
en européen sur cette question d'pipace
et très concrètement le premier
rendez-vous de vérité et de cohérence il
porte sur la révision des règles en
matière d'emballage et en particulier
d'emballage alimentaire le texte
comprend deux dimensions la volonté
d'aller interdire au niveau européen le
bisphénol A
il est interdit en France depuis 2015 et
le deuxième qui consiste à interdire les
pifases dans les emballages alimentaires
nous soutenons cette position et la
France en européen souhaite que cette
règle s'applique partout en Europe
comptez sur notre mobilisation et
au-delà de notre mobilisation compte sur
le fait que dans ces 18 recommandations
nous sommes d'ors et déjà en train de
regarder celle que nous allons pouvoir
mettre en œuvre quand dans quelques
mois monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Louis bricou pour le groupe
yotte merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'écologie monsieur le
ministre face aux enjeux climatiques
avec la fin annoncée de la
commercialisation des véhicules
thermiques pour 2035 il nous faut aller
vite pour décider nos concitoyens à pass
à électrique pour l'acquisition
l'accompagnement des pouvoirs publics
effectivement rendez-vous avec le bonus
écologique la prime à la conversion ou
le leasing social par contre concernant
le rechargement c'est une autre affaire
on est loin des promesses constructeurs
d'un plein à coup dérisoire si vous
rechargez au domicile tout va bien mais
dès que l'usage vous force à dé trajet
long ou à l'itinérance l'accès mais
surtout le coût de rechargement laisse
place à des mauvaises surprises on est
loin des conditions de concurrence
constaté dans nos traditionnell
stationsice pas ou peu d'affichage des
prix aux bornes pas de préaffichage au
bord des routes pas ou peu d'accès au
règlement par carte bancaire pas de site
comparatif des formules de tarification
qui interroge en effet au tarif euros
kilwh peuvent s'ajouter des frais de
stationnement des frais à la minute ou
des frais de lancement de session
d'autre part s'ajoute aussi une
obligation de souscrire à un ou
plusieurs abonnements pour obtenir un
tarif préférentiel dans une enquête
d'ailleurs UFC Que Choisir donne
l'exemple du rechargement d'un une
voiture citadine sur borne lente à Lyon
le coût peut varier de 7,35 € à
68,77 en fonction de l'opérateur bref
monsieur le ministre ces écarts
interrogent une situation qui risque
d'ailleurs de décourager les bonnes
volontés d'acquérir un véhicule propre
je vais déposer une proposition de loi à
vocation transpartisane visant à créer
les conditions d'une réelle concurrence
et à revenir à des prix justes êtes-vous
prêt monsieur le ministre à accueillir
favorablement nos propositions
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des
territoire monsieur le député gu BRI
merci pour votre question et je ne suis
pas je pardon monsieur le député
Jean-Louis BRI je ne suis pas surpris
par votre question parce que je sais
l'attention que vous portez à ce sujet
et la volonté de regarder au-delà des
véhicules comment l'aménagement de notre
territoire permet à nos concitoyens
partout de pouvoir accéder à cette
technologie vous avez évoqué le sujet
effectivement de l'aide à l'acquisition
depuis le soutien y compris pour le
rétrofit la prime à la conversion et
évidemment sur le leasing le succès nous
sommes que nous sommes en train de
connaître avec un chiffre qui à la
minute où je vous parle a d'ors et déjà
dépassé les 35000 réservations en terme
de leasing mais votre sujet porte sur
les bornes non seulement
j'accueille de façon tout à fait
favorable la perspective que vous vous
saisissiez de cette question mais
j'accueille avec impatience les
propositions que vous nous ferez nous
attendons là dans les prochaines
semaines le rapport de l'Autorité de la
concurrence qui s'est autosaisi de
toutes les questions que vous venez
d'évoquer sur les difficultés
d'interopérabilité sur les écarts de
prix qui peuvent être constatés sur les
sujets qu'il y a avec parfois des
déficits d'information on a un plan de
déploiement des bordnes des rechargge
qui nous a permis de dépasser le seuil
des 100000 bornes en mai on est environ
à 140000 on a un règlement européen
affire qui pose des obligations de
transparence que nous allons renforcer
mais il y a en parallèle les pratiques
que vous décrivez et sur lequel entre le
rapport de l'Autorité de la concurrence
et les propositions chers Jean-Louis
bricou que vous nous ferez nous aurons
matière à pouvoir compléter si j'ose
dire les trous dans la raquette et nous
assurer que la décarbonation du parc
automobile est effectivement enclenché
de manière irrémédiable merci par avance
le
truc je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur bricou merci d'abord
merci de votre réponse monsieur le
ministre il faut effectivement aller
vite si on veut pas décourager nos nos
usagers au transition écologique je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est à
présent au président marlex pour le
groupe les
républiain Monsieur le Premier Ministre
pour la 3e semaine consécutive Mayot est
paralysée par la mobilisation de la
société civile qui manifeste massivement
et bloque les voies de circulation la
cause de cette grave crise et
l'explosion de l'insécurité et
l'amplification de l'immigration
clandestine depuis l'arrêt de
l'opération wambouchou qui était censé
restaurer l'état de droit la cause est
également l'absence de réponse aux
alertes des élus de Mayotte en
particulier à celle de notre collègue
Monsour camardine dont la demande de
réunion d'urgence avec le gouvernement
est restée sans suite aujourd'hui c'est
donc la rue qui s'exprime les maoraais
refusent et ils ont raison que Mayotte
devienne le Lampedusa de l'océan Indien
et que les villages et les quartiers
soient placés sous le jou de gang de
criminels qui s'en prennent aux familles
aux travailleurs aux enfants quand votre
gouvernement prendra-t-il donc les
mesures à la hauteur pour mettre un
terme au flux migratoires venus des
Comores et désormais de la Corne de
l'Afrique qu mobiliserez-vous des moyens
de la Marine nationale pour être mesure
physiquement de stopper ces flux quand
présenterez-vous la loi Mayotte que vous
avez évoqué lors de votre déclaration de
politique générale et qui devait être
transmise aux élus de Mayotte dès le
mois de février quand lancerez-vous une
opération wambouchou puissance 2
puissance 4 pour reconquérir les
territoires perdus de la République à
Mayotte et surtout quand reviendrez-vous
sur ce droit du du sol inconditionnel
qui pousse tant de Comoriens et
d'Africains à affluer vers Mayotte je
pense évidemment aux mesures qui qui ont
été censurées par le Conseil
constitutionnel voilà Monsieur le
Premier Ministre les question que se
posent les habitants de Mayotte et qu'en
leur nom je vous adresse je vous
remercie monsieur le Président la parole
est à Monsieur le Premier
[Applaudissements]
Ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le Président
marlex je le dis d'emblé la situation à
Mayotte et ce que vivent les maoraais et
les maoraaises est totalement
insupportable et si cette situation
était V vécu dans un département de
l'Hexagone on en entendrait parler matin
midi et soir dans les
médias cette situation vous l'avez dit
elle
indigne les élus locaux elle indigne les
parlementaires vous avez cité le député
camardine je veux aussi citer la députée
Estelle yousoufa qui est aussi mobilisée
sur cette question là les sénateurs
également qui m'ont interrogé la semaine
dernière sur ce sujet je le dis la
première priorité dans l'immédiat c'est
de rétablir l'ordre public et permettre
la reprise des activités sous l'autorité
du préfet du procureur de la République
les forces de l'ordre luttent contre les
violences urbaines et interpell le plus
grand nombre possible de délinquants et
je veux saluer leur engagement on doit
aussi entendre les revendications des
manifestants je le disais à l'instant il
manifeste face à une situation qui est
tout simplement insupportable pour cela
il faut pouvoir se parler et j'invique
donc les collectifs à saisir les
invitations des élus et du représentant
de de l'État à échanger les manifestants
et les élus je le disais il y a un
instant ils demandent le retour à
l'ordre il demande l'évacuation du camp
du stade de Cavani j'avais été interrogé
au Sénat le 24 janvier dernier par le
sénateur Saïd Omar wailili je lui avais
annoncé que l'opération de démantèlement
de ce camp serait démarrée le lendemain
elle a démarré le lendemain à ce stade
200 personnes ont été évacué il en reste
500 je demande une accélération des
opérations d'évacuation du camp du stade
de Cavani je le dis très clairement et
très fermement je le redis le
démantelllement de ce camp est en cours
et sera mener à son terme le
gouvernement agit aussi sur les causes
de cette situation notre premier
objectif c'est évidemment de prévenir
les arrivées irrégulières à Mayotte en
luttant contre les filières
d'immigration illégal nous avons vous le
savez considérablement renforcé les
moyens pour lutter contre ces filières
nous en avonsv démantelé un certain
nombre des condamnations ont eu lieu et
d'ailleurs es ont donné lieu à des
peines de prison ferme lourd j'ai bien
conscient je n'étais pas dans mes
fonctions actuelles des dispositions qui
avaient été portées et proposé dans le
cadre de la loi immigration sur Mayotte
j'ai conscience aussi que le Conseil
constitutionnel les a censuré je crois
profondément que dans le cadre de la
future loi Mayotte il nous faut remettre
ce travail-là sur la table et regarder
comment ces mesures pourraient être à
nouveau adopté évidemment et surtout
validé par le Conseil constitutionnel je
l'espère pour être plus efficace ensuite
on doit être plus efficace aussi pour
expulser plus rapidement les étrangers
sans titre y compris les ressortissants
de pays africains les déboutés de
l'asile font systématiquement l'objet de
décision d'éloignement tout est mise en
œuvre pour les exécuter dans les
meilleurs délais
50 départs sont prévus cette semaine 100
éloignement sont prévus la semaine
prochaine et là aussi je souhaite que
l'on puisse continuer à accélérer
l'ensemble de ces mesures seront
renforcé dans le cadre du plan
interministériel de lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière le plan
chicandra qui est actuellement en cours
de refonte enfin il faut évidemment
donner à Mayotte les moyens de mieux
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
l'insécurité et toutes leurs
conséquences sur le long terme donner à
Mayotte tous les moyens de son
développement sur le long terme c'est
l'objectif et vous l'avez rappelé du
projet de loi dédié à maotte que le
gouvernement présentera après en avoir
débattu et y avoir travaillé avec les
élus de Mayotte je souhaite que ce
travail puisse se tenir dans les toutes
prochaines semaines je vous remercie je
vous remerci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président
oui merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre
ça fait au moins 7 ans désormais que
notre collègue Monsour Camard vous
alerte moi après moi cette situation
intolérable les résultats ne sont pas là
il faut changer d'échelle et notamment
mobiliser des moyens de la Marine
nationale pour enfin défendre Mayot je
vous
remercie la parole est à madame la
présidente Isabelle roche pour le groupe
horizon merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à la ministre de la
Culture madame la ministre une étape
historique a été franchie vendredi
dernier en matière d'encadrement de
l'intelligence artificielle en effet ce
2 février les 27 États membres de
l'Union européenne ont voté en faveur de
l'a Act la première réglementation
mondiale sur l'intelligence artificielle
il faut se féliciter de l'aboutissement
de ce texte à l'unanimité quelques mois
à quelques mois des élections
européennes ce vote rappelle aussi le
rôle déterminant de l'Europe pour
répondre au défis de notre temps je
voudrais particulièrement attirer votre
attention sur la manière dont l'ya
bouleverse le monde de la culture et des
médias pour nos acteurs nos musiciens
nos auteurs et nos journalistes
l'intelligence artificielle peut être un
formidable outil d'aide à la création et
à l'information pour autant il nous
alerte depuis longtemps sur les risques
d'une IA insuffisamment encadré nous
parlons ici du respect de la propriété
intellectuelle aujourd'hui les IA
génératives peuvent collecter des œuvres
originales ou des articles de presse
sans même prévenir leurs auteurs et donc
sans les rémunérer nous parlons aussi de
respect des données personnelles les IA
sont capables de reproduire l'apparence
physique ou la voix d'acteur parfois
décédé enfin et plus globalement c'est
un changement de paradigme la capacité à
générer des œuvres artificielles va
modifier notre conception de l'œuvre
d'art face à ces enjeux le texte
européen apporte des réponses concrètes
il pose la question de l'accès des IA
aux données en permettant à ceux qui ne
veulent pas que leur travail soit
collecté par des IA de le faire savoir
et à ceux qui le souhaitent d'ouvrir un
dialogue sur le partage de la valeur
madame la ministre avec ce texte nous
devons laisser éclore nos start-up
européennes et tout particulièrement
françaises elles ont un rôle déterminant
à jouer un vrai potentiel de
développement mais pour que l'Europe et
la France puissent négocier sereinement
le tournant que représente l'IA il faut
également que le monde de la culture
puisse se sentir en confiance cet
équilibre entre innovation et protection
est crucial pouvez-vous madame la
ministre nous assurer que la mise en
œuvre du règlement européen sur l'IA Act
respectera l'équilibre du texte et
permettra de créer un climat de
confiance je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est
àadame
culture madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Députés pas très malin madame la
Présidente
roche l'adoption à l'unanimité le 2
février dernier de l'un des tous
premiers textes permettant de donner un
cadre sûr au développement de
l'intelligence artificielle vous l'avez
dit est une réelle avancée d'ailleurs je
dirais même que c'est une première alors
la protection du droit d'auteur et des
droits voisins et le fondement vous
l'avez dit de du notre modèle évidemment
de soutien au créateurs et la diversité
de la création alors moi je sais que
c'est une de vos préoccupations nous en
avons évidemment discuté et vous l'avez
dit les l'intelligence artificielle
génératif se nourrissent de très
nombreuses œuvres protégées par le droit
d'auteur c'est pour cela que avec votre
soutien d'ailleurs que le gouvernement
été très attentif au respect à ce
respect des droits des créateurs
avec le respect du secret des affaires
afin de permettre notamment l'innovation
alors je sais que notre conviction
commune est qu'il est vain d'opposer
innovation et droits d'auteur alors le
texte adopté vous l'avez rappelé permet
un équilibre et nous veillerons ensemble
à ce que cet équilibre soit respecté
vous pouvez compter sur moi alors
évidemment cette première étape n'épuise
pas toutes les questions que nous nous
posons mais je sais pouvoir compter sur
le Conseil supérieur de la propriété
évidemment littéraire artistique qui est
une instance placée auprès de mon
ministère pour accompagner une plus
large réflexion justement sur
l'application la mise en œuvre le
respect de cet équilibre je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la séance des questions au
Gouvernement est
terminée la séance est suspendue